it's 2018 and recreational weed is now
legal in California it's no secret that
up until now the war on drugs and
specifically on marijuana has unfairly
locked up a disproportionate number of
people of color in an attempt to right
those wrongs the City of Oakland has
mandated that half of all weed business
permits go to equity applicants or
people who are low-income and have a
cannabis conviction or who live in a
neighborhood in Oakland that's been a
major police target so now established
weed businesses like this one called
nugg are training these folks to become
hot rope owners
[Music]
kareem robinson is learning the business
of cannabis and at the end of his
training he'll get his own 1,000 square
foot greenhouse he says this opportunity
saved his life two years ago I was ready
probably jump off a bridge and I believe
in God stuff but I'm saying I had no
photo and I definitely didn't have no
plans that I were all my own business
and I grew weed before but never like
this so I'm really excited
Kareem qualified for the equity program
because he lives in an East Oakland
neighborhood with a disproportionately
high number of cannabis related arrests
now he's preparing to profit from a
business he was once criminalized for
the plants grow in what's called the veg
room where they get 16 hours of light a
day when they're ready to flower they're
taken to the bloom room
take them and this is where we we set
them up in a certain position like like
dominoes basically one then one
top of mine here what happens is it
starts button and when it starts button
at these white hairs they start turning
brown I thought you know for sure but
this is where the money or where the
good stuff is made at the top not at the
bottom so this is the good stuff right
here it's ready yeah almost almost
the plants are left to dry for two weeks
you see guys who's like straight up
hangers yeah and as you see like this
different colors because it's different
and then trimmers remove the buds by
hand this right here is where we keep
our wheat our award-winning premium Jack
and under stress these are the pounds
you take a look at it every bag is a
pound every bags in here as a path it's
all different kind of strands Oakland
statistics show how people of color like
Korea have been unfairly targeted in the
war on drugs the city's population is 31
percent white 30 percent black and 30
percent Latino but in 2015
black people made up 77 percent of
cannabis arrests white people made up
only 4 percent even though studies have
shown that both groups use marijuana at
the same rate I've seen police well they
came in here they say they're coming for
weed and they chopped down all our
plants and
took me to jail and they put me on
probation for three months three three
years they use weed of the gateway so
now we don't have that probable call to
stop we don't face for weed and why are
they targeting you because I'm blood and
I know now that weed is legal
white entrepreneurs who have not been
policed for cannabis have found an
immediate leg up
Oakland's equity program is trying to
correct the racial disparity by
encouraging businesses like nugs to take
on equity applicants in return for each
applicant nugg gets a general permit
that could help them expand their
business Nikko Nia is the CFO of
innovations the parent company of Doug
he helped select Kareem and the other
equity applicants we are giving them
fully automated state-of-the-art life
deprivation greenhouses they will have
those greenhouses rent-free for three
years in addition we're giving them
$10,000 for start-up funds it's
rewarding to see and finding that right
individual like Kareem
who appreciates the opportunity and
wants to capitalize on it like how much
could he be making soon in excess of a
hundred thousand dollars other cities in
California are following Oakland's lead
in making the marijuana industry more
fair Los Angeles San Francisco and
Sacramento each have their own equity
programs if you were able to give a
message to the city of Oakland which we
know has targeted people of color
and are now trying to sort of make
amends of this equity program what would
your message open be that they need to
support the equity program more so more
people like me can get a chance because
when the other people are supporting
this thing then they could look at me
and say well if it happened for him
maybe gap for me basically I got a new
start I'm 40 years old at 38 I didn't
have nothing going for me
I have hope now and I do have things
working in my favor hey guys it's Deena
and that was a lot of marijuana to be
around in one day what do you think
about equities weed program should more
cities follow suit let me know in the
comments and be sure to like and share
this video and subscribe to aj+